[Musica]
e così successo qui
perché ci sono tutti i pupazzi a terra
forse è stato merlino
luce di cibo vitale che buone patate
arrosto
siamo qui nel forno vitale
perché ibridi così che cosa hai
combinato
io che cosa ho combinato io eh si io ero
giù quindi puoi dirmi che non sei stato
tu a mangiare il pacco interno di
merendine e vediamo cos'altro cè le
patatine gli strali statua mangiarli no
non sono stato io davvero e chi può
essere stato
no non sono stato io a perché devi dare
la colpa a me magari stato berlino
berlino 10 alla figlia e confezioni ma
chi l'ha rubata e ha distrutto tutto
e che cosa stavi facendo tutto questo
tempo
io stavo controllando le patate nel
forno quanto ci impiegano ancora
quindi se non sei stato tu può essere
stato solo merlino potremmo fare una
cosa chi amiamo berlino e vediamo se
alla faccia colpevole sembra un'ottima
idea
vado subito a chiamarlo e vediamo che
reazione fa ciao ragazzi bentornati
solita stories
secondo voi chi è stato fare questo
disastro secondo castro che non vuole
ammettere lo scopriremo molto presto
assieme
se non avete ancora lasciate un mi piace
mi raccomando lasciate un mi piace entro
oggi queste cody 5 4 3 2 1 o tempo
scaduto se non mi seguite ancora su
youtube mandati a seguirmi l'umanità
stories e se volete seguitemi anche su
tik tok il nome sempre mite stories si
mette vitale ad arrivare con berlino
[Applauso]
vediamo un po berlino il dato to berlino
sta cercando di mangiare un pupazzo io
vediamo un po video chiesta proprio da
bari a da non si mangia nerino prova
proprio mangiare il gatto a questo si
stato tu sei stato tu berlino non è
bravo nella facciata forse è questo che
lo ha rotto le rotto don marino 6 dirmi
chi è stato a fare questo
e visto qualcuno mi sa che lui il
colpevole guarda come si annusa tutte le
carte non mi sembra colpevole avrebbe
fatto la sua faccia colpevolezza il suo
uso colpevole
quindi io penso proprio che ci sia solo
un colpevole si guarda un pò guardà chi
è il colpevole
quel vino va bene sei stato tu non
subito questo non me la racconta giusta
ma neanche tu me la racconti giu non
sono stato io davvero ragazzi c'è
qualcosa che non mi convince
non mi sembra che sia stato merlino ma
nemmeno vitale mi sembra abbastanza
sincero chi può essere stato allora non
so a chi credere
c'è qualcuno là dietro c'è qualcuno là
dietro merlino
no è solo al gup atto che vuoi mangiarti
quindi non siete stati nettuno e berlino
ma a me tocca comunque mettere a posto
tutto questo disastro guarda io ti giuro
che non sono stato peccato che non puoi
chiederlo alle patate da lo
confermerebbero che sono stato tutto il
tempo a guardarle
quanto a berlino invece lui era fuori
tutto questo tempo
questo tempo in giardino e si è questa
come te lo spieghi allora
beh in effetti questo è molto strano hai
sentito ma qualcosa al piano di sotto
non lo so meglio andare a controllare
subito però ok andiamo berlino vieni con
noi
poi aspetta prendiamo qualcosa per
difendersi nel caso che sia un mostro
molto cattivo io ho scelto questa e io
abbiamo
[Musica]
berlino andiamo
non peso nessuno qua to berlino e di
qualcuno prova ad annusare con il tuo
naso merlino ha un po di sonno o un idea
proviamo a vedere se c'è delle impronte
o qualche traccia da seguire
ok questi sono delle briciole dato che
arrivano iniziano proprio da qua forse
partivano dalla cucina laggiù vitale e
trovato qualcosa
guarda si sono dalla traccia guarda
parlano quella parte
fino a dove arrivano non lo so sentiamo
le chi potrebbe avere lasciato queste
frizione un topo o delle formiche
impossibile le formiche non lasciano
così tante briciole deve essere stato
una creatura un po sbadata
quindi o tuo merlino o ti giuro non sono
stato io ma viene qualcuno che somigli a
noi due ma non lo so
serviamo le tracce vediamo chi troviamo
allora partiamo da qui
massimo proprio sotto girano
guardo si terrà pure ma è vero sarà qua
dentro allora
quindi se si interrompono qua la
creatura all animale è sicuramente qua
dentro
chi è
c'è nessuna siamo annusare berlino ok
modo chiamare troppo fritsch atto no per
dirottarli donna che marino lanciate da
berlino dove sono aiutare se c'è una
creatura e maestro troppo tardi berlino
sta mangiando tutto
cosa c'è qua dentro controllo a berlino
non me ne frega proprio niente di cosa
potrebbe essersi fa dentro vuole solo
sgranocchiare visto che il bambino non
ci aiuta l'unico modo per scoprire cosa
è entrato in casa e aprire questo
cassetto ma teniamoci pronti con le
nostre armi al mio via ci teniamo al
cassetto che melo copriamo cos'è non ti
5 4 3 2 1
[Musica]